the Joe Rogan experience my son now is
at the stage where loves holding his
cock just whole horse about it pinches
it at the end is only easier I don't
know it either I haven't got a lot of
baby cocks to reference it against I
think my son has a small cock but it's I
think it grows all right I think he has
a nice erection but I think he has a
very he has erections at 16 months they
have erections from day one Wow like
sometimes you wake him up in the morning
you'll take his nappy off because he's
got a shit in there and it'll be a shit
covered erection
oh that's a weird connection and a good
name for a band it's well ready take it
there's probably a website for it it's
it is yeah he gets like a little tiny
woody and I always think what is going
on in his head where he is wanted or
need an erection what was the dream that
he had last night I know the dreams that
I'm having when I wake up with an
erection what are the ones that I hit
like is that you know that cat saying
suggestive things off the iPad what is
it's probably just blood in his deck
it's very just blowing these dick or
it's longing for something that he you
know I don't know you ever get boners
when you're driving for no apparent
reason
you're not even horny I have yes I have
those are weird those are those who like
seeing yourself in your dick boners
sometimes you got to have sex and you
got to fucking work it a bit to get it
going and then like other time you ever
done that one where you masturbate in
the car while you're driving you neva
you because you've been stuck in traffic
and then I I was alright with it in
Britain but too many people in this town
drive SUVs mm-hmm I Drive it I Drive a
catch Allinger I'm lower down I get seen
by a lot of people get together get into
the windows yeah yeah or or I could just
stop wanking in my car or just get one
of those things that women use when they
breastfeed in public and just jerk off
under that yeah get a quilt yeah I found
out the best thing to do is to plug my
phone into the iPod connection and then
play porn on it because then I'll get
with subwoofer and everything surround
sound port and wicker that's a good move
so do you like hold it with one hand and
steer with like the last time I do I
normally have to be in traffic so I'm
not doing that much steering
how often he beaten off in your car I
since I've lived in LA last five years
yeah I know of three times this is
happened it's not like I'm not gonna do
it like right now Bobby this is like
I've just been somewhere that some girls
got me going I'm in a bit of a frenzy or
I've just had a fight with my girlfriend
I'm in a bit of a bad mood I need to
cheer myself up really I only beat off
once my car ever and it was when I was
driving limos I was driving home from a
gig I had to drop some lady off in New
Hampshire driveway the fuck up in New
Hampshire is long ride back hour and a
half back I got bored so I beat off and
I remember the fucking massive feeling
of disappointment of myself that I
jerked off because I'm jerking off
underneath my shirt as soon as I came I
was like god dammit there's gonna be a
thing I do all the time now and I never
did it again I was shy good for this
right but I'd never came up I never
wanted to do it again but I'm shocked
because I figured I'm such a fucking
idiot once I do something embarrassing
like that I'm like well this is
something I do now this is not gonna be
I'm not gonna like I remember once
having sex with a girl and she was just
yelling it fuck me daddy
fuck me right and I kind of went hey
what do you call me that like this for
and then I slightly enjoyed her saying
it I would thought I don't need that to
be a thing yeah don't make that a thing
for me because then I'm fucked up but I
got to ask other people to do it and
then we're in a real fucking predicament
when I was in Boston I was used to bang
this really crazy Portuguese chick she
used to call her pussy a cunt it was the
first girl to ever ever heard say that
she's like fuck Dutch cunt fuck tactic
she was like angry about it like I hope
I don't start liking this yeah that's
gonna be hard to get someone else to
agree to mm-hm
what a lot of gals yeah it's hard when
you've got a thing and you've got to ask
your girl to do that thick III for a
while there I love Chokin girls while I
was fucking them for a while I'm not as
jokey as I used to be but I used to be I
used to be I used to be very
back in Hana and the neck pin you down
while I was fucking you right and some
girls and because I was Danny girl I got
off and doing that right and that was
that's what got me into it was this was
our mateys and then you meet the girls
who don't want you did it but then I met
one girl who I was choking and then you
know I'm not choking the whole time
right and then I've stopped and she's
sort of thought oh this is what we're
doing is it she starts choking me and
I'm like don't do that that feels
horrible I don't know how bad it feels
for you women but it really hurts my my
old neck the choking thing is not it's
weird it's just like one of those other
things where some people love it and
some people hate it and you never
fucking know until it comes up you know
you could date a girl and have no idea
she likes to be choked like the the
first girl that I ever dated it like to
be choked was so girly yeah she was like
so like you would never she wasn't loud
she always wore dresses she was she
wasn't like boisterous or you know stock
ative or slutty she's a regular girl and
she fucking loved it she asked me to
choke her those I was like what do you
mean choke you like how do you mean
choke you
she was just grabbed my neck why you're
fucking me I'm like okay hard you want
me to hurt you like what's going on here
like and then if you thought about doing
it to another girl they would freak out
like it's weird what like one person
that what's their big turn-on and
another person like it's something I was
bad when you when you bring the choke
into a girl doesn't want it it's always
bad ah I was with a girl that had an
iron deficiency and every time she would
want me to choke her the next day she
would just have like these horrible
bruises around her neck and she just
would have to like wear like turtlenecks
and stuff but it looked like if I ever
got in trouble I'm fucking sorry
you